hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Gotham episode 8 video
Harvey Dent we got to meet Nikolas
Agosto as the illustrious Harvey Dent of
course he's gonna show up again maybe
not that many times this season he said
he didn't know how many times he be back
I know everyone's wondering they're not
gonna turn him into two-face right away
even though there are some really
interesting cues that kind of line up
with his back story in the comics that
I'll explain next week will be the
mid-season finale but it's already been
picked up for a full season I believe
it's 20 episodes total but all the rest
of those will happen in the spring so
lots of awesome Batman comic book stuff
to talk about but let's start with top 5
moments careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet starting
with number 5 Blackgate penitentiary so
the funny thing about Blackgate is that
it was featured in the Chris Nolan Dark
Knight trilogy if you remember as a
result of the events during Dark Knight
they created the Harvey Dent act that
took the worst inmates from Arkham and
put them in Blackgate in this episode
they were doing the reverse which was
kind of funny so it was like they're
taking the worst inmates putting them in
Arkham I don't know how they're gonna
reconcile that continuity we'll just
look at this Gotham TV show as being its
own separate thing for now there are
just a whole lot of things in general
about the Chris Nolan Dark Knight
trilogy that didn't necessarily line up
with the comic books and the cartoons
and stuff so actually I think it's
better to say that Chris Nolan's Dark
Knight trilogy kind of exists by itself
TV shows in general especially right now
all the DC TV shows are very loyal to
the comics much more so than the movies
speaking of paying homage number 4 meet
Lovecraft
new big bad dick Lovecraft as teased in
this episode is probably that evil
person on the wane board that's behind
the venom serum as well as the Wayne
murders no he didn't kill himself
but I do think that he's tied to the
murders it's a bit of a surprise because
he's presented as being just as powerful
as Falcone and Maroni that makes him
almost invincible which takes him to a
big bad status like one of the big
villains of the season of all the people
you could think of as the big villains
this season I feel like he's the one the
writers want you to hate the most it's
like the whole conflict with fish Mooney
Falcone and Maroni makes you want to
root for Falcone especially since the
penguin really seems like the
protagonist and he's the one with
Falcone right now they're on the good
team if you're gonna pick favorites
amongst the villains that brings up a
really important issue I feel like there
are a few the villains this season
they're a little underdeveloped so I
think it's going to take the
next ten episodes before we really
decide who the real villain is for now
though Lovecraft will do and I suspect
that he's named after HP Lovecraft's
Lovecraft I'll talk about Lovecraft a
little bit more when I talk about Arkham
Asylum just because there's so much
influence bouncing back and forth
between HP Lovecraft's universe in the
Batman universe number three Batman and
Catwoman by far the most fun part of the
episode some of their interactions ran a
little slow but I did like the
playfulness between them Catwoman is one
of the few characters they can get
through his armor like get to the real
Bruce Wayne that's why you see Selena
Kyle calling on most of the
stuff he does in this episode she just
poked so many holes in it I would say
their performance was actually really
good for a couple of actors their age
hopefully they'll get a chance to
develop their relationship whatever
that's gonna look like over the next two
three four or five seasons we don't know
if Gotham is gonna get a season 2 yet
but it has been a ratings hit for Fox so
I think it has a strong chance depending
on how some of those episodes in the
back half to number 2 Arkham is reopened
and all the worst prisoners are dumped
in I try to keep my eyes peeled for
prisoners walking off the bus to see if
any of them look familiar
aside from Ian Hargrove the criminal
from this episode I didn't recognize any
specifically I had hoped they'd spent a
little bit more time at Arkham in the
first half of the season but it looks
like that's what they've been saving for
the second half just to explain the
Lovecraft aspect of Arkham Asylum the
actual building itself Arkham Asylum
when it was created in the comics was
named after the town Arkham in HP
Lovecraft's Cthulhu those stories that
is why it looks so haunted and creepy
the writers made it seem like the mayor
only did that only it sent all the
prisoners to Arkham because of what
Gordon said he might have had that plan
all along
if you don't remember from the last
couple of episodes he's pretty clearly
in collusion with the mob primarily
Falcone Lovecraft - Lovecraft also has a
controlling interest in Arkham City so
it's like Lovecraft
the mob and anyone else that we haven't
met yet or potentially haven't met yet
have their hooks into the mayor and the
mayor's trying to deal with all of them
I know there's the temptation to think
of Richard kind the mayor as an evil
character but really he's the Bullock of
the politicians in the city like take
Bullock for instance he's not a dirty
cop but he is caught up with the mob so
push comes to shove there's a good
chance he'd roll over for Falcone or one
of the other big mobsters the mayor is
just a more power
version of that character although there
have been a few theories that he is the
one that killed the Wayne's like killed
him himself I don't know if that's true
but I do like that idea
and my number one moment meet Harvey
Dent played by a Nicholas de Gaston I do
have to hand it to him he has some big
shoes to fill
big coin to flip if you've never
actually read the inscription on his
coin it reads oder 'not dumb but to hunt
let them hate as long as they fear he
explained the coin during the Dark
Knight trilogy but basically his father
was really abusive and would flip the
coin to give him a chance to avoid
beatings I know I've recommended the
Gotham central comics just because it
centers on the Gotham City Police
Department just like this show Gotham
does in that continuity to face falls in
love with Montoya ends up going sideways
out sirs a lesbian that gets kicked back
into Arkham for the mid-season finale
they're teasing some tension with Gordon
but I don't think that they're gonna do
any big two-faced stories outside of
this I know everyone's wondering when is
he gonna become two-face just because
he's a little bit older so they could do
that sooner
right now he's councilor dead I don't
think that he would become two-face
until he became the District Attorney
and only then after being District
Attorney for a long time
Gotham is a prequel show so I don't
expect to see any full-on super villains
till season 2 season 3 I don't think
they can go that long without showing
someone in a costume so I don't expect
anyone to throw any acid on anyone's
faces anytime soon the interesting thing
is that they're teasing this big mob
trial like they're trying to go after a
Lovecraft he's not a mobster but in the
comics it was while they were trying to
take down a mobster that he got asked to
thrown in his face it was inside the
courtroom there been a lot of different
origin stories for two-face so the
details about that usually get changed
just a little bit each time of course
most fun part was when he flipped out on
Lovecraft the comics have explained his
Harvey Dent identity versus his two-face
identity in slightly different ways
typically its dissociative identity
disorder it's not like Bruce Banner and
the Hulk or anything like that
only one identity can be present and
typically you don't see him spending a
lot of time when he's in one persona
thinking about the other persona like
when he's Harvey Dent you don't see him
thinking about to face very often and
when he's two-faced you don't see him
thinking about Harvey Dent that often I
would say of all the Batman villains
that Gotham could possibly do Harvey
Dent is one of the more interesting ones
just because he's a tragic villain there
was even this run in the comics where
two-face worked with bap
but usually at some point he'll get
restored he'll become Harvey Dent
something terrible happened he'll turn
back into two-face so it's like he keeps
bouncing back and forth like he gets
redeemed then he falls down again then
he gets redeemed falls down again if you
guys want to read some really awesome
two-faced stories though one is I had
the beholder let's see what's the next
one
long Halloween that's just an awesome
comic in general half a life that's
actually a Gotham central arc half an
evil that's Batman number 234 and then
faces and that's Batman legends of the
Dark Knight number 28 to 30 I think I
mentioned most of the Easter eggs
already I gave the episode of beep but
that's just because I felt like the Ian
Hargrove storyline like that criminal
storyline just did not work for an
episode that's supposed to tee up a
finale I feel like it just didn't quite
live up to the standard Nicolas agosto
is Harvey Dent best thing about the
episode hands down worst thing about the
episode I would say would be Barbara I
guess I could do like a thumbs-up
thumbs-down kind of thing thumbs down
for Barbara thumbs up for Harvey Dent
maybe I should flip a coin that'd be
more appropriate the only thing that I'm
not enjoying about the Barbara character
right now is the fact that she is not a
character I understand they're trying to
create some tension with a character
that hasn't been featured in the comics
a whole lot like we don't see a lot of
Gordon's wife typically they're divorced
by the time you see him like because you
see him as Commissioner Gordon most of
the interaction we've had with the rest
of his family in the comics is through
Barbara through his daughter Barbara the
same thing totally happened on arrow
with Thea and Laurel the writers said
that for season 1 and 2 they were just
the hardest people to write for in order
for a character to be worthy of our
admiration they have to go through a
crucible Gordon's going through one
right now Bruce is going through one
right now penguin went through one
already just think about all the
characters you love on the show they're
probably the ones that have had
something really terrible happened to
them and they've triumphed over even
nygma got a lot of love in this episode
part of the problem with that is just
the amount of time they have to spend on
characters I feel like Barbara will get
her do eventually yes cheating on Gordon
with Montoya
is tantalizing but I feel there are so
many other things they could do with her
character that would make her more
interesting like they could get into her
family life she's from a very powerful
family
what's her father been doing this whole
time in all fairness I do think that the
back half of the season will deal with
that he was largely absent from the
episode totally loved the penguin though
for the time that he was on screen he
has the best theme music on Gotham that
should give you an idea about who the
writers want you to root for penguin
Gordon Falcone nygma and Bruce Wayne
Catwoman - we'll throw in their next
week's episode is called love crap be
sure to subscribe to get my video I'll
post it right after the episode airs I
will be doing bonus videos in the off
season I'll be doing you know Batman
lore videos so just leave your requests
in the comments if you have any specific
you want me to start with and just a
heads up because YouTube has changed
like a few things and giving me some
extra features the links that I put at
the end of videos will change just a
little bit I'll still have like my
special links here but if you're on
mobile you can actually click up here to
get those links too now as always
everything's in the description - but
right now click here for last week's
Gotham and click here to get ready for
the flash this week thank you so much
for watching now let's all high five I
will see you guys tomorrow
you